at this altitude I can my hands this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
I've used 99designs for years for all
sorts of graphic design needs whether
you need a logo website book cover
anything else
99 designs was created to make great
designs accessible to everyone and to
make the process of getting designs much
much easier so when I first started out
for instance testing prototype covers
and getting prototype covers for the
4-hour body
I want the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one-to-one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen from
using this one-to-one project service
with a handful of different designers
and illustrators it blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim again
that's 99 designs comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront
is the future of financial advice
they've become incredibly popular among
my friends in Silicon Valley and across
the country because they provide the
same high end financial advice that the
best private wealth managers delivered
to the ultra-wealthy but for any account
size and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealth front now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
manners wealth front is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have bloated sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so at the very least
go to wealthfront comm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go to wealthfront comm forward
slash tim to get your first 15k managed
for free or just to get more details
check it out wealthfront comm forward
slash tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types to tease out the
habits routines tactics coping
mechanisms favorite books whatever that
you can apply and test in your own life
this episode features one of my favorite
comedians of all time and he is a young
feller Jerrod Carmichael on Twitter you
can say hello at notorious ro D he is
pushing the boundaries of comedy with
his groundbreaking work and stand-up
television and film now he is just 29
years old and what this North Carolina
native has accomplished in that short
period of time is mind-boggling to me
and I know a lot of productive people we
get into his work process we talked
about how he gets so much done and if
you visit him on social media right now
he has 0 posts on Twitter on Instagram
at Jerrod Carmichael and 2017 is going
to be his biggest year yet so we do talk
about focus and how he went from East
Coast to West Coast and got all of this
done Jerrod stars in the hit NBC series
the Carmichael show which he also writes
and executive produces the third season
of that show is premiering this year in
2017 in March of 2017
this year Jerrod will star in his second
stand-up comedy special on HBO directed
by Bo Burnham he made his debut on HBO
in 2014 with his critically acclaimed
one-hour special love at the store
directed by Spike Lee so love at the
store this is a name I want you to
remember you have to watch this it is
arguably the funniest stand-up special
I've seen in many many years and it's
the reason that I initially reached out
to have drawn on the podcast it left me
in total hysterics on a transatlantic
flight some wine might have been
involved but it terrified everyone
because I could not stop bursting out
laughing out loud while other people
were trying to sleep sorry everybody but
it's that good and immediately as soon
as I got off the flight started texting
my friends guys you have to check out
love at the store so watch that and
you'll know why I reached out Jerrod now
on the big screen this june joins the
cast of Michael Bay's Transformers the
last night opposite Mark Wahlberg Josh
Duhamel am I getting that right do you H
am
yell and Anthony Hopkins he'll also
appear in james franco's the masterpiece
set to be released in 2017 in the summer
of last year 2016
jerrod reprised his role as Garf if
you've seen neighbors he did that in the
universal company sequel neighbors to
opposite Seth Rogen and Zac Efron I
originally met in an indirect way draw
through Seth and Evan more specifically
Evan Goldberg both of whom have been on
the podcast before he also starred as
Freddie opposite Rose Byrne Susan
Sarandon and JK Simmons in the meddler
which was released in April 2016 so this
guy's going nowhere but up as far as I
can tell the most incredible work ethic
and focus of anyone I've met in a very
long time and he'll have an upcoming as
yet untitled memoir coming out through
Random House he's got a million things
going how does he do it
we dig into all of it and we also
discuss dangerous comedy and much much
more so please enjoy my conversation as
wide-ranging as it is with Jerrod
Carmichael sir
welcome to the show thanks for having me
I am so excited to finally sit down and
record this because I remember very very
specifically the first time I was
introduced to you and it was actually on
the working set for neighbors too you
had not yet arrived but your picture was
up alongside a bunch of other people who
were going to be appearing in the movie
yeah and I was on the set because I was
gonna be interviewing Evan Joburg and
Seth Rogen and we were going through a
few of the names I was asking questions
about folks and he pointed to yours
because I mentioned I'd watch neighbors
and enjoyed your particular role in that
movie and he said oh he's gonna be
really big along those lines is what he
said Wow and and then shortly thereafter
I think I told you about this we could
have all sorts of exciting sounds going
on we got a raven running water
a raven who's lost a family I was on a
flight an international flight and loved
it the store was one of the options yeah
you're special and it may or may not
have been the case that I had one or two
glass
oh that's the only way to walk but it
was a sleeper so everyone was asleep
except for me and I'm drinking wine and
watching your stand-up and I thought I
was going to be kicked out of the cab
because I laugh so much and as soon as I
landed I did two things so one of my
friends Mike I immediately sent him a
text when I said you have to watch the
stand up immediately number one Wow
and number two is that I went on Twitter
and this is how we met if you might
remember and I said is the Evan in your
stand oh special and then told right
that's right that's how we connected
that's right and it was Evan Goldberg
yeah who was in the audience for the
show and I just talked to him like just
like midway through the show to start
talking to edit it was great I mean and
you do a few things that I haven't seen
in finish specials before another was
you you will refer to your notes on
stage sometimes yeah for love at the
store like the intention was to just
capture me like a Saturday night at the
Comedy Store you know I wanted it to be
very truthfully we cut for time but like
Jamar neighbors who's this hilarious guy
my best friend went up before me like I
had this guy Argus Hamilton is just like
this legend of The Comedy Store and of
the scene like he was there like it just
felt kind of like a Saturday like we're
doing spots and and I wanted to just
capture and just me working out material
it was very much so like it like an
exercise it was like oh yeah and I refer
to notes cuz I was trying to I did new
stuff on that special you did yeah I did
like new material I also remember asking
you about your interactions with the
audience like at one point you said your
skin is so milky I don't think I've used
that adjective every month yeah it was
it was the thing that popped in my head
like I had sorrows like yeah she had
really milky skin you describe it I
thought it was it was pretty milky right
it was but it was wrong no they're very
accurately described how did you first
connect with Evan Evan I met because I
want to get this right I
like Josh and Alex who work at this
company and then I believe I met Evan
actually on the set of the first
neighbors
I believe he see me you know and and you
know he and like Nick Solar and Seth you
know all about hired all involved in
hiring me but I'm trying to think the
first time we met I think was on set at
neighbors and he's just like this I mean
has incredible energy does incredible
energy is incredible that he'd ever sits
during meetings know he's always
standing or doing like a golem squat yes
he has very good squat form very amazing
squat form he paces around he's like
Pete I mean and so many ideas I've never
met someone who has as many like ideas
as Evan I like just like just like
rapid-fire like and is able to take a
thing and like bend it in in product for
on all sides and he it's it's incredible
just watching Evan in or he's a prolific
generator of ideas in the same and I
remember one of the and we're gonna talk
a lot about I think how you develop your
material and process but I remember one
of the experiences that I had in Atlanta
was sitting in the suppose the writers
room while they were spitballing ideas
yeah one person was manning a keyboard
typing everything in and they had many
many many different revisions of this
script which as I understand it is very
kind of Judd Apatow meaning like what
the script comes in looking at it and
nothing like the impetus to something of
yeah and so they were all shouting out
suggestions and Evan said [ __ ] I think
every third word and it was just typed
right in and I remember at one point I
was like what's next because [ __ ] is
every third word yeah and he said to me
he goes not the important thing and I'm
paraphrasing but he said you you want to
keep the generating of ideas and the
editing of ideas separate and you can
always D you can always do [ __ ] the
script later later that's actually
that's brilliant
you can de [ __ ] the script wait when do
you remember if you do your first memory
of working on comedy or
funny oh that's a great question I think
I was uh so when I was a kid we used to
just record things was infatuated with
protect like the the camcorder and and
and just like record things and do
sketches and you know why I guess our
sketch you don't know what there's no
form right it's like no you're just like
recording whatever freestyle restyling
and you and we like and when you say we
this is Yui the kids in the neighborhood
my family you know everyone's involved
and we're all its I was really blessed
to be around a lot of like creative
minds like people who were just like
down and really creative and like really
excited about just like jumping into
characters and in doing things and so
that was kind of the first experience
just kind of uh but truthfully eighth
grade was really important for me like
just comedy what specifically just
comedy and thinking that I was maybe
funny you know why is great what
happened in eighth grade I had a teacher
who who got me started reading the
newspaper and it was remember his or her
name Oh Kwami Nayeri so this guy all
right you know just with Kwame Nayeri
had me read The Autobiography of Malcolm
X start reading like like the the New
York Times in like the local newspaper
and this is like an eighth grade and and
taking in all this information and like
learning and kind of discovering myself
like humor was just this big it was how
I broke the tension of any information
that I received so I remember
specifically there being one moment in
class I don't know why this stands out
so much but he wanted to have a debate
right and so we were we read an article
I don't remember specifically what it
was about but we were choosing it was a
guy that committed a crime and would
decide and rather not it was justified
and we're supposed to pick sides as a
class and he said well who thinks the
crime you know wasn't justified and
everyone in the class except me raised
their hand and then they were like well
who thinks it was and it was
just me and then for the next hour no
exaggeration I debated like 23 other
students on like just like a wide this
man deserved to commit a crime and it
was the most fun I ever had it was like
it was like having information and then
being able to put your own filter and
manipulate it in in your own way was so
important to me and that's kind of
that's in a sense that's kind of my if
my comedy has a style or an intention
behind it it's it's that eighth grade
class me against everyone else well
that's part of the reason why I insisted
my friend Mike watch your stuff yeah
which I know Mike really well I mean 10
out of 10 hit with Mike also but I
remember watching and I'm not gonna
spoil it for folks there are a few
instances in particular that because I
don't have the delivery and I wouldn't
give you the context I would get in
trouble for just 5 mentioning but I
recommend everybody check it out I and I
think it there will be a moment for
everyone
where you will probably feel extremely
uncomfortable offended or both and that
is good for you it's heavy so I'll leave
it I'll leave it at that but you grew up
in North Carolina North Carolina yeah
how would you describe your family and
childhood we had fun you know like we
had I guess hey I can't speak for
everyone in the neighborhood but we
enjoyed us like much out it was um just
asking a lot of questions really you
know uh really curious about everything
you know in a family that allow room for
that like you know everything was
challenged we questioned everything like
a lot of arguments you know of like it
was constant arguing but fun arguments
you know like amongst the family and
friends in the neighborhood um I enjoyed
it I enjoy my child allow me we didn't
have like a lot of money but it was it
was great it was great it was like I had
a really creative childhood I think how
did your parents help foster that
uh they gave me a lot of freedom and
especially in this neighborhood like I
didn't I've never had a curfew I never
had a like but I would just say all
right mom going out and she's like all
right be safe very much you just set a
prayer and just sit me out into the
world you know and I just me and my
friends we just kind of go out and you
know go get in fights and all the silly
things that you do each other's eyes and
and they just gave me a lot of freedom
like my mom and dad gave me a lot of
freedom so what gave them that we're all
so healthy I hate when I see kids like
being inhibited like it's that you have
to lie otherwise I guess you have to
know the child I guess the specifics of
the child both but like what did your
pants do my mom was a secretary at the
hospital and my dad a truck driver did
that mean your dad was gone a lot of the
time yeah on the road a lot yeah he was
on the road a lot so you know me and my
brother and my mom you know a lot of
times just you know I don't know it was
really I like that the neighborhood it
was so many characters you know like you
grew up in like a neighborhood like that
or the hood or whatever you call it and
it's you know so many characters isn't
is very passionate very interesting
people yeah very passionate everyone
feels very strongly about everything you
know like everything is very straight
like the type of cigarette they smoke
the every every detail is really you
know important to them what was the
catalyst for pursuing comedy as a career
as a profession um it was a thing that I
felt I was really good at I wasn't doing
anything I was in North Carolina I was
like I'm I was working at a you know at
a shoe store and just not really doing
anything let me ask you maybe a strange
question how did you know you were good
that's a no that's a really good
question because it is I mean validation
so obviously we want to have you know
the feeling like inside your heart and
know that you can do anything right also
validation is important from an outside
source it's like I mean you want to
confirm that
I mean if nobody's laughing at some
point you know at some point you know
you no matter how much you believe like
maybe this isn't a strength you want to
apply logic to you know your dreams and
your beliefs and and I and I had friends
who you know spoke very passionately
about one friend in particular who was
like no you think like a comedian like
you really should do this like it's it's
different it's like it's funny but it's
not the way just the guy at your job is
funny it's like different and and she
pushed me really hard to do it and you
just kind of know like it was constant
validation right from where and you know
doing an every situation you're kind of
that guy and you know eventually you
accept it you need to run from it or
accept it were you doing I mean could
you imagine I just like rebelled because
like no I'm a lawyer
Yeah right were you doing open mics at
the time or was it just through Nolan I
started comedy in LA I moved first and
then their comedy because I'm
competitive and you should be
competitive at some point you know
explain that meaning you didn't want to
do it where you didn't feel the scene
with someone yet where the scenes not
necessarily strong and and truthfully
they're great scenes around the country
there's you know Chicago and Atlanta and
in San Francisco has an amazing comedy
scene you know but New York LA you know
really New York for just repetition sake
you know like you can go up so many
times but but la is what like there it
really is the best are here the best and
you're like you want to be around the
best you don't want to just you know
there are a lot of people kind of doing
comedy
everywhere I look there's a lot of
people kind of doing it in New York and
LA too but also you have these amazing
comedians and these people who spend all
of their time for its it you kind of
have to create or go to the artist
colony for whatever you do I think right
like you got to find it and you want to
compete and you want to see what you
have to gauge you have to take the
temperature you know we're not totally
talking about well I mean if you're the
average of the five people we also have
a black helicopter coming to pick up
some special operations folks we're
having lunch
to us so many helicopters like an insane
amount of helices yeah I mean if you're
the average of say the five people you
associate with most then going to where
the competition is the strongest is
really important right it's so important
and were your parents at all worried for
you do you have to have a big
conversation with them about packing up
and moving west yeah it was kind of you
know what I've been thinking about it is
it's been on my mind for a while a guy
came into the shoe store I was working
at my gem-like like nineteen twenty at
the time what were you doing at the shoe
store just selling shoes just selling a
man just putting insoles in trying to
sell you on some cleaner you know doing
the just the the whole thing and I did a
damn good job mind you you know you know
finish line that sold a lot of you know
I think I deserved more I'm at work
right okay a guy came in in he you know
just small talk with a you know a
customer and I'm like you know what do
you do and he said he's an actor he
lives in LA and I was like man I really
want to move to LA and he was like just
move
I was like wait what and he was like
yeah just move and then he got me uh
told me about a Westside Rentals and and
Craigslist and all these things did I
just found a place told my parents my
sister bought me a plane ticket
my brother was excited they were they
were excited my mom was more nervous my
dad was really encouraging but uh you
know you know no one's ever done that
from my neighborhood you know like no
one had ever I mean what is that yeah
just move gonna just moved to Los
Angeles to do comedy
alright seems you've worked out for ya
you always up the shoes to fall back on
anything yeah hey I am not to toot my
own horn but I'm [ __ ] amazing you know
I still can look at like certain shoes
and like I know style numbers just like
style numbers I know what department it
is alright so now what made you good at
selling shoes I think the same thing
that made me good at comedy book
interest a competition competition among
other employees yeah all that was fun
me and uh my friend Ben used to just we
competed on everything like everything
was cuz if you're gonna do it in that
moment like you know you should have a
need or at least a curiosity of well
what is being the best that this feel
like right like sure I went bowling the
other night and you know I first kind of
playing around and then and then my
friends start bowling a little bit
better and I was like I'm gonna start
bowling a little bit better and you just
and before you know it like I'm like at
least at least spares on every Friday I
was like I was hot because competition
it drives you makes you better yeah it
makes you better
I love it so I want to talk about your
daily schedule a little bit because I
find it fast
so do you wake up do you wake up at a
consistent time
it's kind of all over the place
I don't sleep a lot did I ever tell you
you changed my life I don't think so uh
not disrupting REM cycles yeah is
genuinely it's helps so much for someone
like me who really I mean I got four and
a half hours last night which is not bad
it's not bad a lot sometimes I do three
get solid 90-minute days in there oh
yeah like just and actually feel amazing
on ninety minutes of sleep if you're
getting the ultradian cycle that 90
minutes 90 minutes or in multiples of
those 90 it makes it big diff you it
change so I really helped like just I
don't sleep a lot I mean certain certain
nights you know you can kind of catch up
but I'm usually excited I'm like oh I
like read until like 4:00 or 5:00 in the
morning and then that's that's my
programming to you yeah
Late Late Late Late and then because of
certain projects I'm I have to wake up
early right you know like I have to be
up at 8:00 tomorrow which is you know
not ideal but it's fun I mean you know
you're up you do it we'll jump into some
rehearsals or something what is the
first phone call do you make each
morning so my mom alright can you tell
us about this because I don't want to
start my day with [ __ ] I don't like
noise you know I don't like too much
noise right as a helicopter flies above
I don't like noise mom
has a great spirit like one of the
purest people that I know she doesn't
over complicate anything she has such a
grace I love starting I won't take
business calls before I talk to my
sister is what like my the first call of
my day is really important so sometimes
I'll talk to like my sister first as
well if like if my mom's too busy for me
or something but like I actually really
like starting today a very peaceful
brief conversation you know see see what
she's doing
is it just a general catch up or is
there what are you doing today just
carries what Varrick hears is what she's
doing what she's interested in you know
like I talked to her for a few minutes
and then I'll do other calls but like
you you want to start it you know in a
very peaceful place and then yell about
marketing for now right you need a
pallet there's like spiritual palate
cleanser first exactly exactly
cuz that first moment like you know you
you just jump into a thing you know that
you want to send it yourself first for
sure before just a particular way you
end those calls just kind of a sweet I
love you you know like a tweet or me I'm
more aggressive than she is so me you
know like hey make sure you I'm trying
to make sure my parents are hydrated so
I'm like I eat like fuss at her about
water every morning I'm just like
alright ma you know yeah I have a couple
leaders today and which is insane to her
and something about moms and not
hydrating I don't know what the hydrate
no really yeah a lot of a lot of mothers
of my friends also their sons or
daughters are all know about drinking
more water more water my mom and dad
like I everyday just like how much water
did you drink like it's the question so
I'm more combative than she is she's in
such a great constant state of Zen and
I'm just like me about how much you know
I'm like fussing at her about why I love
life that's great let's talk about the
water yeah yeah yeah yeah how many
ounces exactly and so but she it's just
a great way to start the day see you I
have and I ping Kevin before we met up
as I mentioned just trying to get some
let's to talk about one was he seems too
well and again I'm paraphrasing this but
seems to eat the same things and eat at
the same places constantly and then we
sat down we had a bite to eat
just uh maybe 20 minutes ago and you had
scrambled eggs and blueberries yeah you
said this has been your default was it
lunch for the last Brett well breakfast
well whatever time breakfast is but idea
for years blueberries and eggs it just
feel great blueberries and eggs you know
and and I used to do almonds now walnuts
start the day you know like that's the
I'm a creature of habit you know and I
like the restaurant and I like I like
everything to kind of move efficiently I
like the you know the rhythm you walk
into a restaurant you know what you're
getting you know you you bring friends
they're familiar with you you're
familiar with them saves your brain sexy
yeah exactly because you can put all
that energy toward like creating
thinking figuring things out you know
see you also mentioned something and I
was like wait hold it I don't wanna talk
about it I want to talk I do want to
talk about when were recording that you
had a uniform for a very long time yeah
yeah I was wearing the same I bought
like a lot of the same shirt it was just
like white sweatshirt gray pants like
timberlands every day every day
it worked in any place that I went
that's what I like it worked every way
eligible I go to I'll go to your wedding
and this thing I go and just the same
thing in it because it took out so much
time in my morning not sunny that's very
much Eve job Z and that's what he did
yeah but now I'm like off a little bit
it's still kind of in the same why did
you change
I mean clothes are fun you know I like I
like certain club and uh you know go
through a phase and just and and I'm
picking out like you know a lot of like
wardrobe for like the show and stuff
like that so I'm thinking about clothes
Nate you know but but you actually you
want intention behind everything so you
know I was just wearing the same thing
it was perfect I'll go back to that
aisle and well we go yeah I'll go back
to that what do you think your next
uniform will be or will they the same
thing it worked they work but maybe
switching maybe of maybe a gray
sweatshirt go crazy white James purse
sweatshirt acne jeans hit some
turbulence that's it every morning you
don't think about it stay just in stacks
I just had stacks of the shirts and
stacks of the pants and just grab just
grab the one off the top do you remember
the first time that you bombed what was
the first memorable bomb ooh about prep
my first set your first set first set
was just I mean atrocious this is open
my open mic at the Comedy Store nobody
was in the audience
there was no it was an open mic I went
up first at the open mic the the Sun was
up I was competing against the Sun and
it's this giant window and it's where I
taped my first special was like the
giant window at this is in the original
original room of the comedy so yeah and
it's it's August and the Sun is up and
they're just comedians in the back so I
guess technically technically I didn't
bomb but it wasn't a it was a it was a
soliloquy I was just doing a soliloquy
up there it wasn't comedy I just went up
and did ya just gotta talked and talked
way too fast and got off the stage way
too fast
yeah how would you coach or what advice
would you give to a comic you see
someone they do a set and they just bomb
and they're new and they come off and
you can tell that they're totally
demoralized what do you say to that
person it's just people what do you mean
like the Ani is its people we're all
just people you know it's no you know
you go do it again but I honestly
sometimes the bombing indicates that
you're going to you know some type of
new territory for you and only you know
you so like sometimes it's good it's a
good thing it's kind of like a cleansing
you know and so you can't run from it
you you know you tell yourself it'll
never happen again it will but tell
yourself that it won't and go do it
again
you know and stop you know a lot of I
wonder if it's like this in I mean I
know comedy really well but everyone's
like kind of looking for like rules
right so follow and and soon you realize
there aren't any the the better art can
be you know like it's like
people start looking for like what you
got to do this first and you you know
arm and for that first special I
remember um I got a lot of like flack
from especially like older comics you
just like we checking his notes on HBO
what is this kid doing you're like
you're on the 10 commandments of comedy
yeah we're we're we're you know ii mean
Mort salt chose you know you spot like
like you can do whatever you want you
can eV and people don't accept that
people don't know how free they are my
understanding with the just to talk
about the original room did they let
cameras in there a lot that was the
first time anyone type anything in there
how did that happen uh I mean we pretty
persistent I had a really specific
vision you know me and my my friend
Andrew had talked about specifically
what it would look like and what that
first special would be and so it just
had to be that room so it was just
pretty insistent and you know now they
of course have the power to say no right
so you just hit them with the same pitch
40 times in a row yeah well then but kid
number one but on the thirty fifth times
smile more smile you had a little we
were just pretty I mean that that room
had been very special to me and it just
kind of worked out we you know I'm very
thankful they had never done it before
but there was no it just cuz you've
never done it before so you know I guess
you were able to convince them you know
HBO I wasn't just bringing you know it
was just like me and a couple friends
with camcorders this is like it's like
HBO you're a year older VHS yeah let us
let us release this like this was HBO
you know and and and you know because of
that certain amount of exclusivity I
think it was a good first time for them
yeah I think so I think so people have
recorded in their since but like Noah
and especially in that room yeah yeah I
had my first ever walk through tour of a
Comedy Store buy it was Bryan Callen a
while back you know Bryan Callen bought
me my first car and I'll let really
bronc
and of Davidoff bought me a car I will
never love also one of my favorites he
there they're both incredible I I am I'm
so thankful for them and like really
like it was like Bryan Callen Duff David
Albright Ernst look out for me out
magical will look out and all these
people were just like really bill burr
would was like so nice to me and but
Brian and of bought me a car
Wow like you know because I was like
walking and like you shouldn't do it and
I got like a text like go pick up your
car like we've done a weekend in La
Jolla and then on that Monday that I
just got a text I go pick up your car
and I mean it's one of the nicest things
Brian is maybe he's a sweetheart
honey he's so great and he walked me
through and he said yeah and then here's
the table you can see all the scratch
marks from razor blades oh yeah we're
all the there's a little piano in one of
the green rooms and it's a little tiny
glass piano not a real piano it's just a
table coffee table it looks like one
it's so many lines that we like to be my
friend Angela used to like to point to
the lines and assign them a certain
comedians others richer prizes like
there's a sign it's like his razor blade
signature is what other routines do you
have that are important to you are
things that you repeat you mentioned the
food which for me is extremely key yeah
I don't want to have to think about what
that for breakfast
yeah locations I repeat locations all
the time you mentioned the clothing
which is something that has been true
for me for a long time but I've aspired
to have a uniform yeah more of a uniform
also to make me care less about what
people think of my external appearance
yeah if you just have like a white Hanes
shirt and jeans it's totally fine and if
people are judging you because of that
then people the people that matter
realize that all that you should focus
on is the work right now it clothing or
all these things as it relates to work
are important right you know like like
it's a lot of intention behind like like
I said like wardrobe for the show with
that type of thing I think about that
because I think everything should have
some type of intention behind it but as
far
just like I look I mean make you feel
good I mean obviously clothing can you
know make someone feel good but focus on
like what focus on something of
substance that means something you know
and that's why because if you if being a
creature of habit works so good because
you don't spend a lot and you were
talking about like listening to music
while working right and we're talking if
you spend all of your energy trying to
figure out where you are and we reorient
yourself like like alright well what is
this and you're looking around you're
not focused on what you're supposed to
focus on so you go to the same place you
sit in the same spot and you just so
then you can ignore everything and you
can just you know be directed inward
well we were talking about music just to
touch on that because I'm able to work
to certain types of music mm-hmm
generally instrumental often electronica
but it seems like neither of us can work
to jazz yeah I want to figure it out I
play it and sometimes in trying right
but I just want to figure it out it's
like man witness Miles Davis doing right
now trying to dissect what's happening
yeah you wonder how on a whole and and
so I have to I just listened to it
separate I can think to it you know and
like just but but if I'm like writing or
from trying to work on something really
specific like just silence what what are
some of the best decisions that you made
in the first few years of your career
you land in LA do you remember any of
the decisions that maintain a certain
amount of exclusivity for yourself what
does that mean uh I think for instance
like you don't go don't go we're just
talking about habits that it's gonna
seem like it immediately contradicts it
but but like even like open mics I
wouldn't do the exact same open mics
every time because you do it you do well
and then move on to the next place like
stay in motion you know and that's but
that's specifically for you know what I
was doing I'm sure it applies to other
things too but you know don't stay in
one spot too long you know is don't get
too comfortable
you know like while working you know
like while that sounds like the complete
opposite of what I just said but I mean
it for like doing
they end up in like that type of things
like well it all hit up the same spot
it's like well there's also a big
difference maybe and started in to
interrupt but I just thought that maybe
there's a big difference between having
habit and routine for training
yeah then performing you want to be able
to do that in different environments
write it out absolutely absolutely that
it that yet training is one thing and
when you work that's thank you very much
save me complete you were doing fine but
what if I wait wait what know it yeah
but but it is that it is that like and
so that was really useful
um surrounding yourself with like-minded
people all my friends I'm the thing that
I feel luckiest with is like the group
of people that I'm around I really have
excellent friends who like care about
like making things and creating and like
don't get caught up in trivial things
that won't matter tomorrow like we don't
get caught up in things that don't
matter tomorrow don't get me wrong we
like new experiences and like you know
having fun but we like work I mean I was
at my office with friends until 6:00
this morning five or six this morning
just like just work and it yeah it's
context yeah the own Saturday night my
attire said it I don't go out really
like a you know like do too much like
you know every now and then but for the
most part like just work and my friends
think like that you know you seek them
out was it luck how did that happen
did you look at the people you met and
say alright this guy talks about too
much trivial [ __ ] I'm just gonna
have to spend less time with this person
yeah you had it how did that happen you
can kind of see it in certain people you
know one of my best friends re we we
both have like such small socialize
virtually non-existent socialize that
that it just works like we aren't you
know we'll go work like right after this
I'll go meet up with them and we'll go
right and we enjoy it it is so fun and
we don't get like it's not like
when I if I heard someone talk about
like I'm gonna find a bar to go watch
the game at while that sounds fun and I
really I'm really happy for you I also
know that we're just doing 250 different
channels really two different channels
like it's like wait why are we gonna
find a bud what I mean watch it on your
phone in between writing or in between
doing what you do bullet what what are
you doing have you always had that focus
on deep work is it because I'm doesn't
sound this way but is because you were
maybe unpopular in school so you spend a
lot of time alone like what where do you
think that comes from or is it something
that your parents really instilled in
you um my parents definitely hard
workers you know it was I'm really lucky
to be able to do something that I enjoy
you know a lot and so focus on my time
and energy into that but uh yeah like
why cuz I again I like focusing on
things that matter you know you go into
a nightclub right you go to a nightclub
is a lot of good-looking people hanging
out right the thing that really changes
the energy is when someone who's
accomplished something walks in right
like you know like you walk in and it's
just people that there are some people
just there to party and there are
certain people there as like just a
briefest escape from doing something and
those are the people so I would rather
be that guy than just for sure you know
you're just gonna hang out spectator yes
spectator like you don't be a spectator
in life in any capacity like go do
something okay so speaking of clubs this
is another bullet from Evan so he said
and this you feel free to refute this
okay so evident his wife took you do it
took you dancing at one point and he
said he had never been to a proper dance
party before not really yeah this was
this was in uh in Texas where a South by
yeah we're we're in South by and it was
like the Lisa was saying we're gonna go
dance and I was like oh really
I was like I really went to just a dance
like that type of dance but I had never
done it before it so we went and just
like that it was fun it was like it was
like really final think of
since it was fun I'm Wade of a way to
forever at least you know they take me
give it was really really fun that's
true that's so rich it's so rare that I
like go out and I'm trying right now I'm
I haven't done stand-up in a little
while I'm trying to try to squeeze in a
few more like like new experiences and
things like that like when I came but I
found myself getting bored constantly
like if I'm not working I get bored
Evon at least that night was fun yes I
need I'm so I feel like I've been
cheated on by Evan he's never taken me
dancing no may not have much but if if
you were to think of anything that
occurs to you as mistakes that novice
comedians or stand-up comedians make
what is what are some common mistakes
people focus on the wrong things there's
there they're a lot of comedians who
aren't funny at all or don't have stage
presence but have excellent websites you
know they have excellent websites and
and the shiniest business cards and the
headshots are impeccable and who gives a
[ __ ] you know what I mean like they
focus on the wrong things go if you
focus on and we actually just talked
about that like if you focus on the work
I think that's all it is like just focus
on the content focus on exactly what
you're putting out if you had to choose
three comedians of any type to combine
into one super comedian mm-hmm for
yourself right now who comes to mind and
what and why would you pick them
understanding that I'm sure you have a
lot of influences and there are a lot of
incredible funny people out there but
just like an aunt like current they
don't alive or dead Oh
ooh that's interesting Richard Pryor I
mean just for being wrong out you gotta
say Richard Wright he's the the Tupac of
God every list also probably might one
of my mom's if not favorite comedians
top three yeah yeah yeah he's I mean
because he was
right so richard pryor for honesty
buh-burn oh he's a friend of mine but I
mean it a whole heart like bo burnham
because he's one of my favorite people
to just watch perform he's such a
performer he's he's like you your eyes
never move away from him while he's on
stage you're always excited and he's one
of the most brilliant people I've ever
met and oh that's a good one that's a
good what's a good that third spot is
heart because it's like a you know Lewis
Black has amazing time and Ellen draws
people in in such a great way Ellen
DeGeneres Ellen DeGeneres is so God well
I told I did a show and I thought I was
like you got to do stand-up again she
was really good at stand oh man that's
it it doesn't have to be just three I
mean you can take yeah I mean they could
be like those are yeah those those that
are named look great I mean you know
it's hard to say Cosby nail to someone
without been a slew of other questions
but I mean as far as the comedian he was
that me excellent and I mean his rhythm
in control over a room was great Chris
Rock man it's hard yeah yeah I mean
they're large they're like yeah there's
a lot of greats out there what in
general do you think separates a favored
Pels
obviously incredible incredible what
separates a good working comedian from a
great comedian good from great I think
honesty you know and by honestly I mean
just like your own truth whatever
excites you whatever you're excited to
perform or say or do on stage you know
being honest to that an understanding of
perception because as a performer you
you I mean you have to know how this is
coming across right and you have to
adjust accordingly because you know
sometimes you want to make sure the
intention is showing and sometimes it
doesn't sometimes you think you've been
like I've just gotta get on stage I'm so
you know like I'm honest and I'm these
thing and it may seem like you're just
bullshitting you don't like right you
have to be aware of what the audience is
seeing you know yeah in a you know of a
business sense like a a sense of
realizing that it is the you know an
industry you know it is because a lot of
times comedians get frustrated with
certain things but it's like yeah that
that's part of any of business like you
know understanding business to a certain
extent is really important I think
having an appreciation for it helps to
you know if you can learn to appreciate
the you know it's hard with art because
you want to keep it separate you want to
make something that's pure we also want
to know how to market it and you also
want to know how to you know that's
really important stuff I mean as you
pointed out with the shiny business
cards on the websites it's the marketing
can turn into a crutch and a tool for
procrastinating doing oh yeah work yeah
absolutely absolutely you make this
thing and then you figure out all right
well how do we how do we get this in the
right hands you know how do we make sure
the right people see and hear this
you're onstage persona seems and maybe
this will sound strange but a little
darker than you're through in real life
yeah persona what's is that a deliberate
decision or is that just how the inner
truths come out what is the it's a
certain amount of comfort on stage it
I'm in this environment where I can
share these thoughts no matter how dark
or how weird they may be it's like you
know it in this lovely setting I wish we
see this in this lovely Center sitting
in an outdoor garden with wooden tables
with our pomegranate tea sparkling water
and blueberries yeah yeah it's it's
super delightful and not the place for
some of its darkest thoughts and like
things that I want to explore I mean I'm
open to any conference I actually prefer
you know the real or the conversation
the better like you know small talk is
obviously boring and you don't want to
get caught up in that type of thing but
but
on stage I'm just so comfortable sharing
you know it's just it's something that
kind of clicks and you just say oh okay
this and I suppose that's the
environment for it right that's the
environment that's where you have the
immunity bracelet - yeah as the sort of
class socially you have certain cautions
I'm sorry you have certain cautions and
certain things certain things that you
don't want to cross because you know
again in this environment you don't want
to make people uncomfortable and they
may not they didn't sign up for that
right but I try and enter stage with
zero fear zero fear and just yeah this
is one decide what do you say - to
achieve that state of zero fear I'm sure
repetition has a lot to do with it but
let's say before your special mm-hmm
the first special what did you would you
say to yourself before getting on stage
or what did your pregame look like um I
try to keep it on like I'll just honest
- any performance uh that that when I
remember just being in the back and I
remember there being like a couple too
many people in the greenroom you gotta
like gotta ask to leave and it just you
just want to think about jokes and like
the you know the first taping I was too
aware of the production and then the oh
that same night we do two shows so then
the second show it was just kind of like
yeah I'm not I'm not thinking about the
production at all like I've just want to
think about the material cause that's
what we wanted to capture so I was in
the right space by the second show the
first show still kind of a producer you
know and I was still cameras and this
type of thing in a bit more you know the
hands-on and and then the second show it
was just you see much you seem like a
very confident guy when do you have
self-doubt or can can you remember a
point any time in your life when you had
like a particularly dark period or a lot
of self-doubt I mean as a kid when you
if you don't know exactly who you are
then it leaves room for so many
questions so and that's self-doubt
manifesting itself in that form of just
questioning everything about you and and
once you kind of figure that out so
truthfully humor played a big role in
that like so
I'm kind of have a similar demeanor
since the eighth grade I think since the
eighth grade since discovering that it's
kind of been a similar you know vibe for
me just like you know I know what I'm
good I don't know what my abilities are
and anything else I don't really care
about what's your position on writer's
block it's I mean it's necessary you
know it's a it's a necessary it's
natural you know there you can try and
get yourself out of it you just kind of
have to release it and maybe a lot of
times I realize for me it means that I'm
holding on too tight and I'm trying to
I'm trying too hard maybe there's a
certain thing and I just need to like
let it go how do you do that focus on
some notes you know focus on focus on
something else and then it'll come to
you this is very this is a very exciting
location it is very exciting oh there
are a lot of people on a balcony yeah
there are yeah a lot of people jumping
around and also screaming on the balcony
and and it looks like it's gonna end or
a man just skated out on a but I was
gonna end very bad yeah there's a lot of
excitement I don't know immediately
what's a negative way oh there's no way
this ends good there's no way oh there's
definitely domestic abuse going on in
there s-someone
i mean if you see something say so but
I'm saying see a poodle and it looks
like it's on the edge of the precipice
but yeah so what's going on today
yeah what types of things do you shift
your focus to when you're trying to let
go does that mean you go bowling does
that mean you a lot of moving a lot of
times yeah I like taking in other
content you know so maybe watch a movie
watch something that's interesting read
a book go on a walk mm-hmm I haven't
been walking as much as I used to I used
to walk around all the time I did the
other night in the rain it was one of
the greatest nights of I just like
walked around in the rain for like two
hours and listened to Marvin Gaye that
sounds amazing what precipitated that it
was raining and I had two hours I had
two hours free it
late I was a I should have been asleep
but I was like oh it's raining I was
leaving a dinner and I was like oh I'm
just gonna go on a walk I was like I was
on my way back to my place and I was
like now I'm just gonna go on a walk
mmm and I didn't think it was gonna be
that long but it was like two hours in
the rain the hood off kept the hood off
just let it yeah it was great I did you
decided to keep the hood off just wanted
to experience the rain it was right you
know like everyone I don't want to be in
the rain I'm gonna be in the rain right
you know you got to do it don't deny the
experience and not the experience like I
saw just walked around it was great you
mentioned books do you do you like to
read it's fun it's really fun I like I
like biographies and I like you I've
never been a guy that got into like like
novels and we're talking about like
science fiction books earlier because I
always like information like I was like
I was like I want information you know
lay in and then I'll create a thing but
I just want information but I read the
book the sellout sellout yeah it's it's
exit the language is it everybody yeah
yeah of um it reminds me of like
language wise of like a confederacy of
dunces lair the language is so good it's
soaked their scent I literally was like
driving around repeating like the
sentences from the book just over and
it's so good how did you choose the
sellout was it recommended to you or
yeah a friend of mine recommended it to
me and it just wanted I mean I'm sure
I'm sure a lot of people have read it
one I can't remember that I like the
Booker Prize what's up right and when
the Booker Prize yeah but a friend of
mine recommended it to me
and the language in it is I mean wrote
the language excites me you know because
it's it's so it's so well written
crafted so well crafted is you know is
these lines that you just I wish I could
think of you mentioned the you mentioned
Malcolm X are there any other
autobiographies or biographies that you
could recommend
oh I wish I remember who wrote it but I
read the Humphrey Bogart biography bit
that I love kind of wish I knew the
author I can look it up and up put it in
the show notes for folks yeah and he and
his his story is so interested in just
like him kind of starting so late
you know like or getting the recognition
so late but but like any good thing like
we found a man who knew who he was by
the time he achieved stardom he knew
exactly who he was so so if if you were
talking to someone because this has come
up a few times who had the self-doubt
because everything was open to question
hmm they hadn't discovered something
like comedy early on how would you
suggest they learn who they are
sit alone be alone sit in silence
you don't mean like late and I'm not
just saying like some you know shaman
esque experience weird someone will just
sit like sit and think go like groans
are like get to know yourself and be
honest with your like the responses that
you have you know mostly into things
like know where you gotta have an honest
assessment of yourself honest assessment
of your life and know what you get and
know where you can contribute the most
find out where you can cannot always
through work you know like a lot of
people sometimes we would make the
mistake of like thinking it's always
through what you you won't always have
necessarily that career but you your
life can be fulfilled and you can
contribute in a meaningful way you know
to those around you to you know your
environment so just try and contribute
well I think the way you said just
before that also is really important and
that is being aware of how you
emotionally respond to things yeah
because I think a lot and I did this for
a long time I learned how to mute that
because I was trying to be so hyper
analytical that it didn't pay attention
to my visceral response to yes and that
is this massive computing power of the
subconscious that is telling you
something and I learned to override it
for so long yes and I only really in the
last few years have felt very
comfortable in my own skin it's because
I've started to I think in part pay a
lot more attention to that if I'm
sitting with someone and the deal
they're pitching sounds great but I just
feel often then yeah I pay more
attention to that now because this is
someone that you're going to work with a
lot you know that you're gonna have a
lot of interactions with and if
something is off if it's just not right
then then it's something's gonna go
wrong
yeah you know like it's gonna hit it's
good that that feeling is going to be
addressed either immediately or it's
gonna be delayed and I'd rather address
it now up front and avoid yeah I was
like a disaster he
and 10x compounded disasters later
exactly and it took me a long time to
learn that a good contract doesn't make
a good relationship at all at all at all
it's basically just this is what happens
if we get a divorce but it doesn't
ensure you're gonna have a good marriage
[Laughter]
when you hear the word successful to you
who comes to mind
oh man jay-z Steve Jobs Jerry Seinfeld
Oprah all all good names all well no
names is there any particular
commonality for you honesty they're
themselves they're very unapologetic
about being themselves that's pretty
much and they've found a way to let that
come out in an artful way like in it
like and through that work or their art
and their careers like they found a way
to to build a career around them as
opposed to you know governing themselves
it was I perceive as a career exactly so
those are the yeah I don't know if
you're much of a gift giver but do you
give books or anything else to people as
gifts like what are your go-to gift if
I'm excited about anything then I try
and share it with everybody in my life
immediately if I if I go to a new
restaurant and I love it all of my
friends have gone that with me at some
point I'm bringing everything everybody
you I need you to share it I need okay
and I also want to talk about it with
you you know I want to have an exchange
I want to like analyze that I love that
that's what I live for so like if I love
a book then I I sent it I send it to
everybody what is the last book or any
books that come to mind that you've done
that with what's the last book that I
sent to everybody was a there was this
there was this book by Eric Butterworth
discover the power within you that kind
of interpreted the Bible in a in an
interesting way
to me and the way that I feel like I
always knew and understood it you know
the way I wanted to understand it and it
articulated it in such a great way that
like everybody really religious not
religious it it's it's really good about
discovering self about answers being
within about that Eric Butterworth Eric
Butterworth his name makes you want
waffles does now especially since you've
now said it now I really well yeah do
you remember the title or I can find the
title
yeah discover the power within you I
don't like the title yep so you know
yeah sure oh it's very it's a bit on the
nose like nothing else
I guess it's good I mean you know there
are no unanswered questions in that
title but but I send it to everybody I
mean atheist friends got that book you
know what I like about like that book
people I noticed what people the people
who got it in the people who didn't it
was like accepting certain truths sound
really cheesy yeah right and you can get
yeah people won't allow themselves to
accept it like the like certain you know
that you are what you think and you are
what you believe types of things and
like that you do need to affirm certain
principles that like sound super cheat
and don't get me wrong like because I
analyze everything and I've like pick on
everything and I get that it's if you
can get beyond right that and just
accept it and don't make yourself feel
guilty about it sure I really think it
like a lot of principles in it can
change your life I makes me think of a
guest I had on some time ago shaycarl
who's a huge YouTube celebrity is I
think close to 3 billion views now sane
and he's also very a typical YouTube
star in the sense that it's the
Shaytards
it's it's it's Shay and his family
mm-hmm
bunch of kids in Utah and so it's not
the typical fast cut you know 18 year
old making videos for 12 year old setup
yeah it's it's very a tip
all nonsense but he said whenever and
again paraphrasing but roughly when you
hear a cliche pay attention because a
truth is being told and I'm not sure
that's true of all cliches I don't think
it is but I've come to appreciate things
that I always disregard it because I
heard them too often like water under
the bridge don't cry over spilt milk yes
you you learn to turn off your
interpretation of that you just
disregard it disregard it and you're
looking for well what's the real answer
it's like no no that's actually really
deep yeah if you think about things that
your fourth-grade teacher told you yeah
I'm gonna truth yeah oh hey I can be
anything yeah it's hard to accept
because the world just Jade's you did it
makes you what is the world doing us if
you had to give say TED talk about
something you're not known for so it
can't be comedy mm-hmm probably can't be
television can't be writing what would
you what topic would you choose choosing
the right friends she was like I think
that like choosing the right people to
be around that will spark certain things
within you and knowing how you can use
each other mm-hmm you know and how you
can contribute to each other's lives I
think that could so this is this is such
an important topic for people listening
who say yes I want to learn more about
this is there is there some
recommendation or an exercise or an
action step or something I should do
more of or less of is there an action
that you could recommend don't disregard
don't dismiss anyone right actually look
yeah this is gonna sound so cheesy right
but there's already given them the cat
already yet so at my best I do this like
this exercise and I could have read this
somewhere I'm not even saying that I've
made this up I think I did but I may
have read it somewhere so my apologies
but it's a like I pretend I'm at the
bottom of a well and every face that I
see I imagine them being the face that
peers over inside and has the ability
to help me and and like rescue me from
something and it makes you look at every
everyone looks first of all amazing when
you're at the bottom or at the bottom of
well and everyone looks in and and and
in that that's like just an exercise for
just people in general but it really
means that everyone does have an ability
to give something to you and just kind
of looking for that and searching for
that first right in people it helps
tremendously I love that yeah that's a
really visual yeah that's for me which
helps Dylan's really hard when you see
it you if you do that like I was a like
outside a movie theater and I was doing
it once and just everyone looked
everyone was a glowing you know like
everyone was just like oh man you thank
you thank God for you I'm so happy
you're here outside a movie theater are
you waiting for someone or were you just
I was loitering loitering literally
loitering outside of a movie theater
like years ago I was like I left the
movie and I was just sitting outside of
it loitering just kind of thinking -
sitting with yourself being a weirdo
being a guy who clearly doesn't have a
girlfriend
[Laughter]
what is the war so what is bad advice
that is given out frequently in your
world and you can define and you can
pick any world that you're involved with
anything that begins with you gotta do
anything but you got out in my world
where do I begin
it's mostly it's 99.9% bad advice yeah
and and it's such a new scary world like
especially in entering into comedy or
television or film and you're looking
for answers yeah you know you're trying
to figure it out but nobody knows what
they're doing I know everyone's making
it up you know and it's a lot of times
it's the sort people can only tell you
what works for them and maybe that
applies to you you know like as far as
technical things like maybe that applies
to you maybe it doesn't so even just
like I don't know the worst thing is
just like looking
it was probably like looking for like
advice I just don't don't listen to
anybody or if you're looking for advice
and it starts with you gotta you gotta
see see when you got it like it's
usually people like aren't where they
want to be yeah the the person who just
readily hands out advice is usually not
where they want to be you know like busy
busy people aren't just around in the
back telling you what you got to do next
although if someone finds you loitering
in front of a yeah yeah yeah I maybe you
know I like to think our lawyer the way
Socrates does but we all like to think
the best of ourselves man what is your
favorite or do you have any favorite
failures meaning a failure or something
that was perceived as a failure by you
or other people that ended up setting
the stage for greater success i I did
they had this Comedy Showcase in San
Diego years ago it was just starting off
and it was the NBC diversity showcase
and I should have never done that should
have never gone down I went down to I
didn't make it to the final round
mind you thank God oh my god it could
ended horribly totally because I had had
I had I made it to the final round I
would not have a show on NBC why do you
say that because it would they would
have put me in a box on the diversity
kid first
yeah the diversity champion I would it's
like like winning like Miss America like
go around and like you're by a Raymond
wait yeah that's your that it's
immediately like a box that you're in
I'm so thankful I didn't lie and it's
really just the thing that people do to
feel good about feel good about
themselves like the corporation's do to
feel bright so you know like I'm so
thankful I call that one of my biggest
mistakes do even going I'm so thankful
that I didn't make it to the final round
of that cuz it would have ruined
everything
like like seeking seeking seeking
any shortcut or easy answer as always
was that you no question the pyramid
scheme of its keep of comedy of comedy
yeah yeah like like so so I'm really
happy I did that because it made me
ignore anything that could be remotely
like I would for me personally and I'm
not because people have benefited from
this and have turned it into lucrative
amazing careers but for me personally
like any I would never do any type of
reality-competition type no I wouldn't
lie I just what I always refuse that and
like the closest I came was like within
my first year doing that how do you walk
and maybe it's not a fine line but I I'm
sure people think about this how do you
establish a unique style yourself mm-hmm
without getting pigeon-holed listen to
yourself
yeah listen to what you want to do and
if you don't want to do it anymore stop
change you know like grow change evolve
you are unique you know it's the only
the most unique thing you can do is be
yourself yeah you know this has got to
sound like a real substitute teacher
right now who is a Groucho Marx or Oscar
Wilde I always confused this to but it's
like be yourself everybody else is taken
everybody else's I can't there's yeah
it's a perfect way of saying it like
that and if you want to sound like a
substitute teacher I'll just sound like
a fortune cookie or like the back page
of a newspaper that's full of quotes but
also you mentioned something earlier
which was the people the people who
matter don't mind and dr. Seuss has a
great quote just that the the people who
mind don't matter and the people who
matter don't mind yes yes exactly it
really dr. Seuss got it yeah dr. Sears
had a lot to him yeah yeah that guy was
oh man
I wanna like I will go on stage and you
you see a lot what's interesting about
comedy is that you get to see a lot of
immediate examples of what you're doing
like like just like a it's like um you
mean in terms of immediate feedback it
meet well not even not even feedback but
like the competition type of thing
like like if you're in the like in and
maybe in a tech world like some type of
Expo you know like where you get to see
what other people are doing right what
comedy that's every night every night
there's a new you know is it's a
showcase like the 3e or not 3 what's the
electronics expert OC es CES and all
that type of stuff in the you know it's
like Comic Con every night you know like
you just seeing what everybody's doing
right and and so you get to you get to
know where you are in context of your
world pretty quickly well especially if
you've chosen to put yourself in a place
like LA yes that's why it's important
for me that's why it was important and
to some people I mean it's good I mean
I'm sure you couldn't find immediately a
story that it was like well this guy was
in you know Kansas and did all right for
himself but like I really think that
knowing where you fit in in context like
if you know doing a television show I
watched all the television shows but
doing film I'm watching every film
especially currently cuz you want to
know where you fit in cut you want to
know where you fit in and history and
you want to know where you fit in the
current landscape so it's important to
be informed
you know for me again I do for me it is
you know I like to know so when you
moved out here to do comedy did you have
in your mind any back-up plan
like if the comedy doesn't work out or
I'm gonna give myself six months or any
type of thinking along the way and be
for me I mean I had an aunt who the
closest I came to a plan B was that I
was in our life for a little bit and
I've an aunt in New York that I was like
well if it doesn't work for some reason
here and I'm just homeless then I'll go
stay with her mm-hmm you know I know
that's I mean that's why I'd be right I
mean that's a split it's a mentally you
would there was you dearest if D risked
it for yourself in a way yeah but really
that was even like a that was a long
shot to make right you know like Eva and
I would have been just gone in New York
and done the exact same thing that I'm
doing here right you know like so it was
kind of just another route to play in a
for me that's a good point that's a
really good point I didn't think about
yeah it was I was just so that was the
closest to Abby it was like a Zygon
in 8.5 just taking another yeah what's
the yeah exactly
alright well cuz I was just here just
doing stand-up and I was like well and
that was purely a logistic thing where I
was like what if I can't
like I just literally can't sleep on the
street I guess friend of which I would
have been I truly I would have been cool
with for a little while like God thank
God I didn't have to but I would have
been cool with that I loved it I loved
doing comedy so I would have just gone
to New York and just you know stay there
if for whatever reason at some point you
stop liking comedy let's just say but
you need to keep yourself busy what
would you what would you do instead I
take an educated swing at something else
I don't know uh I just stopped liking
comedy or you were like you know what
I've been doing this for let's say down
the road you're like 20 years 30 years
in okay I just need a gear shift for a
little bit to come back to this fresh uh
no I'll probably do some weird artist
stuff go like you know be like Bob Dylan
start painting you know like just like
record some songs in a in a nice
basement and I'll release it under an
alias you that type of stuff it's
probably something creative or or or
something like really specific or just
substitute teach for a little bit you
know I just see what the yeah I don't
know I don't know alright well hopefully
you'll be in love the company for a very
long time to come if you had a huge
billboard you could put any short
message on it or an image non-commercial
just to get something out to the world
what would you put on it oh wow I mean
come on man that's a great give you
second you're gonna have to edit out a
long pause oh oh that's I like to pause
this I'll let the silence do the work on
this one
oh man this is yeah I mean
yeah this is really this is genuinely
huh cuz you're like probably don't
listen to anybody don't listen to
anybody
yeah you know like and obviously that
comes with the obviously you'll
collaborate with people and you'll be so
inspired by others and they're people
that you'll work with and but what I
mean is just like anything that directs
you away from you ignore it or anything
that starts with you gotta anything that
starts what you got it ain't got to do
anything they're just bad grammar you
got it I have to use background alright
so they're two two things from Evan that
I wanted to make sure I hit yeah so the
first one maybe we may not explore for
very long
the last point he said was he has an
eight-foot penis so did that come about
because of the scene yes I haven't seen
the filming yeah I I don't know where
that came from I don't know it may be a
thing I never thought I would have to
clear that rumor of it's not that long
that's that's one code that's that's the
other the other direction of like wonder
what girl's gonna want to sleep with me
when you have to coil around your waist
like a silence cumbersome I think you
probably didn't expected me to bring
that I guess but I'm trying and watch
it's gonna hit me like in the car later
oh wait oh that's what you meant by that
something else cribs yeah yeah exactly
we can have it run on the credits the
point that I think we might be able to
unpack a little bit more is he's
mentioned that and you talked about the
newspaper earlier and I guess it was
Kwame is that his name yeah yeah who got
you reading the paper that you can read
something say in the newspaper and then
use it somehow on stage that night and
what helps you to do that or how do you
be in tune with your your feelings you
know you and your thoughts and how in
your true feelings like I will say a lot
of times all um I'll I'll be able to
like say a joke the first time and it's
kind of a finished product you know like
I'll say there was a thing that was like
online of just me talking about
chick-fil-a that was virtually my first
time doing that joke I think I'd like
maybe mentioning the night before but it
was like the first time it just sounds
like a finished product because it's I
don't know I know how I feel about this
I know what I want to say and the points
I want to hit and then you say it and
then that's it so I think it is just
like kind of being and so if you're in
tune things come out a little bit you
know easier do you is there anything in
your creative process for developing
material that is unusual when you when
you describe it to other stand-up
comedians or other people it's a good
question I mean Pro yeah I wonder what's
unusual about it cuz they're I mean I
think I ignore a lot of things that
people don't like meaning like industry
stuff and you know like the things that
I think things that matter to a lot of
comedians don't necessarily matter to me
or I realize that focus it's kind of
limit what we said earlier like focusing
on just myself in the work it's that
thing that you know so I I think I
ignore more things than like a lot of
comedians have you what helps you to do
that do you say anything to yourself in
particular is that just hardwiring yeah
I mean it's it's both emotional and
logical to me like you know emotionally
it's just like well if if I don't think
that I can if I don't think this is
meaningful then I'll cut it out of my
life and logically if you look at
history you'll see the things that fall
out and you'll see you can read this but
that's why I like reading biography see
you read about people's mistakes and
read about the things that ultimately
didn't matter so it's like I don't want
to focus any energy on anything that
doesn't
Oh won't matter right yeah the
distractions of life you have the
distractions of life yeah I mean that's
probably like that's yeah that's
probably why I'm not like and also that
is a personal thing because it for
instance there we were talking about
like social media right and certain
people are great in a source of you know
inspiration and the source of like great
content on social media for me it
doesn't contribute to my life in a
meaningful way so I don't do it yeah
yeah this is gonna this is a left turn
but all these are left turns so I guess
we're just going in a square kind of
counterclockwise anyway what is the what
purchase of say less than a hundred
dollars but just any purchase really is
fun that has had the most positive
impact on your life in recent memory
probably ever like a notebook notebook a
notebook and pens like just right and I
don't even write out jokes but I write
out thoughts we're not paying notebook
goals and thoughts or goals and thoughts
yeah what do you have particular type of
notebook that you like I mean my fit my
grandma would get me some for like
Chrissy's these little small
pocket-sized when the little but really
any notebook will do just any like
notebook that end of Bolognese John in
Venice or the two most impactful the
Bolognese Jonathan only a said John and
Vinnie's in notebooks what types of
thoughts do you write down because we
all have a million-plus thoughts a day
what types of things do you write down
really anything that like anything that
sticks out how I feel about people how I
feel about me what I want what I just
like anything that's like worth just
kind of journaling essentially you have
a strong it seems to tie back a lot to
what you were mentioning earlier which
is your emotional response to different
things yeah exactly that's exactly what
my emotional response it's like capture
I want to know because you see it if you
look at it and if you write down a goal
like you have this image now in your
head it's not just this floating thought
it's an image that you have in your head
what types of goals
would you write down um I'll write down
really like general and like specific
thing can you give any a that's like
really the the two first career goes I
remember um I wrote down that I wanted
my first time doing stand-up on
television to be HBO and I wanted a show
on NBC and I'm writing like those are
very bright goals but but I wrote down
specifically like the HBO thing and
actually as I was like just doing
stand-up and going over like Oh thoughts
like preparing for the first special I
actually grabbed an old notebook and the
one I didn't realize I written it in and
the night before we taped and I kind of
like open and I turn the page and there
it was like the goal like HBO special
did you write it down once and then it
was embedded for you yeah I can still
tell you exactly how it was written on
the page as like I skipped a few lines
it was HBO's written in big letters and
then I wrote like like you know just a
couple sentences about how I wanted to
look and feel documentary is written
down so wanted it to be a documentary
and like specific like ideas about it
same thing for the neck we just did it I
just taped another special and same
thing same pay I like the word invasive
invasive I wanted it invasive I wanted
it emotionally honest I wanted it to go
past just jokes and I don't want to just
tell you jokes you know I don't wanted
it just to be real and a you know
exploration like these certain words
that I think you know was captured I
mean bold directed and it's like really
I think he's brilliant and he captured
it so perfectly but yeah these really
personal things well I think you are one
of the most honest and dangerous and the
best way possible comedians out there
today
thank you very enjoy your work do you've
any parting thoughts comments requests
of the people listening and then I'll
ask you where people can find you and
everything you up to no I mean no try
the Bolognese the Bolognese and then I'm
going to try and I'd recommend people
try the face at the top of the well
exercise oh I like that
thank you that's perfect you
plugged it for me a job it's uh I really
want to see if I if I created it or
stole it from someone I genuinely don't
know no no I was doing face at 30 yeah
mine out is like in the towel to change
you know I mean everything that is
always wants to do again uh this has
been a lot of fun man I really did it
yeah and what a great environment all
sorts of weirdness we have uh a wooden
horse to the left of us yeah horse horse
it's like a retired merry-go-round yeah
it's like we're tight it's like it
retired here there's a lot happening
right now
and I wanna let you get back to your day
where can people find you what you're up
to what can they check out where should
they start anything you want to tell
them be around there may be loitering
outside a movie theater probably walking
around LA or New York
website social nah nah all right I'm
gonna sneak it into the show notes for
people interested it's there I can find
you yeah I'm around you guys all right
guys I I will put links to everything
we've talked about in the show notes as
per usual and you can find those notes
links as well as every other episode if
four hour workweek comm forward slash
podcast all spelled out for our work
week comp / slash podcast and until next
time thank you for listening thank you
and thank you sir
live around too soon hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and 500 Friday
is a very short email where I share the
coolest things I found
or that I've been pondering over the
week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed this episode
is brought to you by wealth fronts
wealth front is the future of financial
advice they've become incredibly popular
among my friends in Silicon Valley and
across the country because they provide
the same high end financial advice that
the best private wealth managers deliver
to the ultra wealthy but for any account
size and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance for harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealth front now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have loaded sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so at the very least
go to wealthfront comm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make
should so go to wealthfront comm forward
slash Tim to get your first 15k managed
for free or just to get more details
check it out wealthfront comm forward
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by 99designs I've used 99designs for
years for all sorts of graphic design
needs whether you need a logo website
book cover anything else 99designs was
created to make great designs accessible
to everyone to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers for the 4-hour body
I want the contest drop that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one to one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book the Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
something incredibly good really some of
the best illustrations I've ever seen
from using this one-to-one project
service with a handful of different
designers and illustrators it blew my
mind 90 and I designs makes this all
very easy and efficient so you can check
out the Tao of Seneca design and other
work that I and your fellow listeners
for that matter have done on 99designs
at 99designs comm forward slash Tim
again that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim
you